hello everyone and welcome to our
webinar on attribution management and
bidding in a multi-device world
I'm your host dan beaver which simply
learn and this webinar is all about the
amazing aspects of attribution
management which may be unfamiliar to
some people but because it's a new and
fairly recent development attribution
management is really getting the
attention of pay per click experts it
offers this potential to shed a clear
insight on the precise degree of
influence that each marketing touch
point has on the eventual conversion
attribution management and bidding
techniques can help you identify
authentic and richly rewarding marketing
and advertising channels and maximize
ROI so today brad geddes who's the
author and world renowned adwords expert
is here to share some of the best-kept
practices and secrets about attribution
management including the various models
and even how to automate your bidding
based upon attribution I'd like to
introduce you to brad geddes
brad is our guest today he's the author
of advanced Google Adwords he's the
co-founder of analysis an automatic ad
testing and pay-per-click recommendation
platform and Brent frequently writes
columns for search engine land
co-moderators the AdWords form for
webmaster world and he has key noted in
spoken at more than 85 conferences and
has led more than 60 AdWords seminars
plus he's a course advisor for the
digital marketing curriculum here at
simply learned and I'm really proud to
welcome Brad Brad how are you good good
thank you Dan
well thanks for joining us I always
check the audio first can hear me okay
oh yes we can hear you this is fine
thank you very much excellent excellent
so hello everyone so today we're going
we're going to talk about you know
attribution management and what that
means from a channel standpoint and a
bidding standpoint so we're going to go
through what is attribution and why
should you care about this the
attribution models and then how to use
them how to pick a model from a bidding
standpoint
and then even how to import that model
in the AdWords so you can automate your
bidding now the reason we talked about
this this is a research that Microsoft
did a couple years ago on one person
buying one camera and so what happened
right is someone searched didn't click
they searched later they clicked they
searched again on a different device
they clicked they went back to a
different device clicked a couple more
times and finally bought so the question
here right is where all these clicks
worth do you want to bid on every one of
these clicks do you only want to be on a
couple of them and so this is where
attribution starts to come into play
that says ok that first click is very
valuable I'm going to when's the end not
so much the elements super valuable and
how do you want to evaluate when a user
come to your site multiple times from a
channel and a bit standpoint you know
within one conversion process so I think
about why does that tribution matter
well first it's understanding how to bid
right when you think about you've got
all these different keywords and
audiences and display in multiple
channels attribution says this is really
what this visits worth to me in this
path it lets you understand how each
channel contributes to your final sales
it helps you determine channel budgets
or if you should remove a channel
determines the value of awareness versus
closing right how does some account
aware of you which the journey look like
what made them finally become a customer
it looks to see how you should treat
generic versus brand terms and it really
lets you you know market wisely use your
money the best best option possible now
we're going to walk through the channels
but unfortunately we look at most
companies we say how you pick an
attribution
it's almost always the CMO picks an
option the chief marketing officer and
it's often not an option based on data
it's based on opinion the whole highest
person's opinion is what you
you regardless of what the data says and
so we really want to do is shed some
light on various models so that you're
making informed decisions about how you
pick a model so when you look your
analytics and this is a company where
their first path link someone clicks
just one thing goes for site it's half
their conversions right well okay so we
say Wow half our conversions in one
click that's pretty good we're doing
really well well it's only half the
conversions but it's twenty one percent
of the revenue that's it if someone
comes 12 times or more to this
particular site that only makes up 10%
of conversions but it does make up 33
percent of their revenue and so this is
why we need to think about this is when
you've got these sort of inverse
relationships the more someone visits
the higher their check out amount is it
says it's not just about last click
right and a last click environment which
means we give all the credit to the last
entrance to the website we would be
bidding the most for those one path link
interactions that 50% conversions which
is only one-fifth of revenue or an
attribution let's to start giving up to
credit because that that 12 touch point
user makes up so much percentage of
revenue and so what often happens right
when you start looking at various models
say okay if we look at paid search by
last interaction we have a $16 CPA if
you look by first interaction with $11
CPA if you look by position base we have
a $13 CPA in so this is just data this
doesn't tell you how to interpret the
data or use it it's useful for my
channel comparison standpoint but really
want to look at why does last click
really matter why does the first
interaction matter and why is the data
so differently and then what's position
based so we think about wise click last
click interaction
means someone clicked on your link and
then converted everything that a
previous that is not counted in last
click and so last click gives 100% of
the conversion value to the last
entrance to website so while in a long
journey it may not be a good bid method
what this does tell you is what closes
the sale
what's that final interaction point to
get someone to close now there's a lot
you can even if you use an attribution
on which we're going to go through
there's there's a lot you can pull from
this because these touch points are the
ones that you want to be hard selling on
right if you think of a call to action
of like learn more versus buy today
well learn more is not that useful if
they're at that last an action touch
more you wanted you want to do the call
of your free assessment or you want that
that harder call to action that says
it's time for you to you know actually
do something now and become a customer
and so when we even think about how does
our marketing message change throughout
the funnel right give awareness right
hey we exist we've got that
consideration phase if we're learning
and that we have by right this tells you
what happens in that buy phase so even
if you don't bid by last-click it's a
good evaluation model to see what's
closing customers because want to make
sure that the ads at this part of the
funnel are much harder sales now the one
issue you run into you with with Google
Analytics is Google Analytics looks at
what is the last entrance to website
before someone converted so the probably
you went up a lot of times is that
you're missing tracking somewhere or
users got something stripped out and you
see a lot of direct in your conversion
so what last non-direct does so
direct means we either didn't track them
or they typed in our URL directly right
and then they finally bought so what
last non-direct does is say if we
removed the last direct touch point and
we went up to the previous touch point
that has a channel associated to it
what is that channel so this is very
similar to to last click except this
removes the direct part and so if you
are a company focused on direct sales
you are a you send out a lot of mail
mail Flyers and say you read this you
kind of are citing you you convert right
that is where last click or last
non-direct click is useful from bid
standpoint when your only direct
response focused
now the opposite of this is first
interaction a first interaction says
what's the first time we had a brand
touch point with this user who then
later convert it so what you'll often
see in really large enterprise companies
is they value first touch dramatically
this is the opening of the conversation
this is the awareness generating touch
point so if you're really focused on
generating more awareness and getting
more people into your funnel that's
where first touch point first
interaction is very useful so now when
we think about our marketing messages
what our ads look like right this is not
a hard sale piece this is now the
welcome to our company here's how here's
all the ways we can help you out now
this is the learn more touch point watch
a video touch point right not the hard
sale and so it's useful to look at your
first interactions and say how are they
finding about us or are they learning
about our company let's make sure that
the ads work we're putting there on hard
sales that turn people off but they are
welcoming someone to come to our site
and learn more about our offers next we
have linear so linear says someone comes
to our site four or five six times
before they convert let's value every
touchpoint the exact same now from a bid
standpoint that's not useful right from
a bid standpoint the first and last are
by far the most important touch points
right how they hear about you what
closed them where linear is really
useful is saying is this channel even
contributing to pushing people forward
so for instance for our company we
started a new channel about six weeks
ago and so yesterday right we'd only
spent now five or six thousand dollars
on Channel and we're looking to say how
is this done
because from a direct standpoint it was
off or it was like we should give her
this money but when we looked at linear
we saw about 10% of all the new
customers in the last but about three
weeks let's ramp up have actually
touched the such one right now it's only
creaks the data it's so early so we say
well we're not going to remove it yet
because it appears early data says this
touch point is moving people forward and
their overall touch once becoming
customer so we should make a note in our
project management system that says
let's check back in on this channel into
three or four more weeks and see is it
truly pushing people forward or was that
sort of like an anomaly of early data so
when you're thinking should we even use
a channel is this channel useful should
we get rid of the channel linear is a
really good evaluation method that will
show you if that touch point has even
contributed to the users finally
converting we have time decay time decay
is one where it's focused towards what
closes the sale except it values most
recent interactions - closing more than
first interactions so we work with a
company who believes our direct response
they believe hey we average highs people
buy we only care about direct response
for direct response that's it except
when looking analytics we see that their
average customer is three point five
touch points before they convert so they
want to be direct response they're not
actually direct response and so the the
compromising is to use sort of a time
decay method that says the closer
someone was to converting we're going to
value that more but okay we get some
people do come two or three times
so let's value that a little bit less
but focus more on what's really closing
those sales on the end
and then we have the one that says
position based we value first touch
point and last touch point the most
right how do they find us how do they
hear about us what closed them though
those are the two that we're really
going to value the absolute most and
then we're going to take the rest of
credit maybe we give 40% to first ties
to 40% the last types take that middle
20% we're going to divvy it up
among the other touch points in the user
journey so this for many companies this
is a good model to start with because
that values how'd you find us right
what's that awareness use your first
touch point to make sure your ads say
hey welcome to our company it values the
last touch point a lot what made you
close but it doesn't forget about the
middle journey now the the downside of a
position based is let's say your average
conversion is five touch points and so
maybe you look and say okay we're going
to give 30% of our credits to the first
touch point 30% to the last touch point
right so at 60% of credit use we have
40% less left and we've got three in the
middle so we're going to value each one
you know about 13% for some companies
that lowers the bids so much of its a
bidding standpoint that they disappear
completely from results in the middle of
the journey and so that is the one
downside of position based is that it
may undervalue your middle one so much
you disappear and you lose you're full
of middle and you need to look at that
model is and so regardless of the model
you pick but you want to do is benchmark
here's how we are today then we want to
put them out of one place we said okay
after three weeks four weeks how do we
do with the bottle in place
should we get more conversions very
number one do we get more revenue are we
looking at our customer base and saying
okay we are now touching how they're
dealing with us appropriately through
each stage of the overall funnel so you
can customize these all right so when we
look at something like position based it
often starts with 40% first 40% second
20% for the middle and so the downside
of that right it is a lower bit so what
we often use is some simple rules it
says if our average conversion it's less
than four and a half can we use whatever
the default in a bid settings are if
it's longer than that right now we need
to give some more credits that minimum
or actions are so many middle
interactions so in that case you can go
in you can actually start to change the
percentages you're allocating so
everything now finally we have an
attribution another important piece of
this is a look back window right look
back window says how far back in time
are we evaluating this data so by
default you generally see 30 days now 30
days may be fine and sort of like a
retail b2b to see interaction often in
b2b you end up with conversion processes
which are 35 45 60 days and potentially
years so in cases like that you often
want to increase your look back window
so that your value more touch points but
the average person comes to you five
times over three months and you only
look at last 40 days of data you've
probably cut out but two three four of
those touch points which is how they
found you and what pushed them forward
so just as important as what model you
use is also you look back window how
much time are you using right looking
back and aggregating your data
so last year Google came out with a
data-driven attribution system and still
with data-driven it says here's all the
touch points there's all the pathways
we're going to use machine learning to
figure out our percentages now the good
side of data-driven attribution right is
if you have a lot of conversions you
have a lot of sort of wandering pathways
right users don't go through a nice neat
pathway system everyone's a little
different how they convert the different
touch points and so data driven starts
to look at based on how they found you
based upon how they closed what is the
value of those touch points in the
middle right and then can aggregate it
and push it out now you need a lot of
data fist work well by by default
data-driven attributes nothing called
DDA you'll hear you'll hear it said uses
linear because it's the flat model to
start with and so if you go down a
data-driven route with few conversions
you're really just bidding on a linear
method right and so but the downside is
without a lot of data you're better off
picking your own model if you have a lot
of data and you feel very strongly about
a model so very strong about position
based then just put position based in if
you don't feel strongly and you have a
lot of data you just won't see how it
works
that then DDA can be very very useful to
get into now the other thing we we often
want to look at is what's the Assisting
value of channels are those touch points
and so this is where we often see is
people make mistakes when they ignore
assisted values so this was a company
and they were doing fairly well on paid
search and when they looked at you know
here's our keywords with conversions and
here's our keywords without conversions
and then here's our spent thought Wow
rate are our keywords without
conversions is most of our spend is most
of our actual keywords we should just
delete this this is you know by everyone
Sanders right this is wasted spend so we
shouldn't actually you know use these
keywords any longer so you know based on
the recommendation from their agency
they went and they selected a thing the
last twelve months so this keyword
doesn't have a conversion last twelve
months we're pausing it and so that
we're going to save a whole lot of money
by doing this and month one was before
they did a pause they had to nurse at
the conversions and then they went to
little under a hundred and then they
went to 55 and they said we did
something really really bad so we need
to go and put those back and do a
different type of evaluation on our data
because we just sort of shut ourselves
in the foot bought by what we made uh
following best practices here and so
when they split it up and said here's
keywords without conversions but have
assists right what was happening was
users were searching for generic based
words this was actually a flower nursery
so people would search for how to plant
roses attending to tulips what pretty
rose gardens and they were going to this
website and saying wow those are really
pretty pictures and they would think
about it and they'd walk outside and
look at where they may plant a garden
and and they remember the website so
they would go search for the brand click
buy so what had happened is almost it
was like 98 percent of their conversions
were only on brand terms and so what
happened as soon as they do
we did all those generic words no one
found their sites to see their pretty
pictures and their advice so then they
didn't know the brain to search for and
so when you have that type of query that
goes how to raise roses versus best
weather for planting rose bulbs versus
the brand name and that's that was a
very stressful funnel for them right
they needed those other words in place
so people heard about them right that's
that in their case that generic word was
that assist value was that awareness
factor and so when we think about things
like hey let's bid based on conversion
values
well the question is what's a conversion
value right there's a word that leads to
100 conversions but doesn't have any
itself this conversion value is 0 then
you're on a bid system you should be 0
but when you use attribution models it
puts fractional conversions in your paid
search account you'll see this keyword
has 0.35 conversions 9.25 conversions
and it brings that fractional value into
Adwords and so then when you set your
bids based on your target CPA your
target revenue you're actually bidding
by that assistant values now another
good place to look at your attribution
data is when channels overlap and the
main reason why is consistency in feel
and messaging so we'll often see this as
a big holiday mistake we see a lot of
companies make is they've got their
website and it's you know blue and green
and it's Christmastime and so they
decide hey we're going to send out the
holiday themed emails that are you know
red and white we're going to make a
landing page which is red and white and
someone who might have been in their
site several times right knows there
knows the look and feel ghostess holiday
page and like who are they I don't know
this company
because that initial feel that same
brand isn't there and so if you think
about here's our display ads and here's
our organic listings and potentially
here is even television so forth if your
channels do not overlap at all you can
have fun with what your pages look like
in your design and so forth
if you have huge overlap then you need
to be consistent in that messaging to be
consistent in the imagery right we'll
see companies who you know go to paid
search link or paying for one make sure
we get a conversion let's give them 10%
off and they put 10% often every one of
their their paid search ads and then
their emails we've already been a
customer we have their email let's just
send a reminder to log in and buy
something right and now they have a
mismatch and let user searches they see
a discount if they see an email they
don't right and now you suddenly have a
brain mismatch and this is why a lot of
companies have brand guidelines imagery
guidelines color palette guidelines it's
to make sure that users have a
consistent right experience with the
company cross channels so the main
reason to look at overlap right is how
do users go through different channels
before they buy because if we have
different experiences by channel we
could confuse users right if we don't
then we could do whatever we want to now
attribution it does take work right you
have to go in you have to look and say
what model do we want we need to
evaluate the model we need to look at
overlaps by Channel when you look at
Assisting conversion values so it does
add some work to your plate the question
is does it matter right so this company
they are direct response 90% of their
conversions 90% of their revenue is
one-touch it is that same day this day
someone find
is a day they convert and when we look
at okay what if he takes longer what if
he takes two or three different times
where they come back a week later
it is completely linear in the
percentage of conversions and percentage
of conversion value so the customers
don't get you know better or spend more
or spend less based on unday lags
they're just a direct response company
so if you're attribution looks like this
you may not really worry about
attribution that much when you're
attribution looks like this right it's
u-shaped you the more someone comes back
to your company the more value they are
worth now attribution is very essential
because that user who comes to your site
four five six times is worth a lot more
than the user who comes once or twice
right so the more they do research the
bigger their purchase value is right
that's a huge learning experience to
take away of it's not just about touch
point get them and have them buy
something but the education of the users
so that they're buying like the most
expensive products while the product
that really fits them and they start
building things together in their final
conversion process so if we we jump over
to AdWords right assuming you've got
your Google Analytics account linked to
your AdWords account when you go into
your conversion tracking and you hit the
edit button you have the option to pick
an attribution model so by default it's
last click that is the default model
that is used or what's the last touch
point before they bought something but
you could choose data driven
you could choose first click you can
choose time to care your position based
in so when you add an attribution model
like this into your conversion tracking
that's where you get fractional
conversion set of AdWords you know about
a year and a half ago or so all the
conversion columns went from
one two one point zero zero right you
have this to the decimal point in those
two other fractional numbers and most
companies just see 0 0 & 1 or why Google
at point zero zero across all of my
conversion data because if you're using
linear and someone comes to you four
times and they buy once each those touch
points is now I'm not going to say one
or three say zero one say one all will
be 0.25 if you're using position-based
you'll see you know point four point two
point two point four and so this is why
Google made the different that change to
show fractions and conversion columns
because if you go when your truck
conversion tracking and you're using
Google Analytics conversion tracking and
you're pushing the attribution data you
can now do fraction conversions so now
your account will have fractional
dynamit so this also means then if you
choose target CPA bidding you do bro
us-based bidding where you let Google
set the bids for you if you're doing
attribution modeling with fractional
conversions in the account then you've
actually automated the attribution
bidding for the account and so if it's
you know a lot of work to do all this
then essentially it's go to analytics
pick an attribution put it in your
AdWords conversion tracking
turn on CPA bidding or Rojas bidding
you're now bidding by attribution models
but the question is when you see these
models which one do you want to use
based on your company type and data
driven it's always there you don't have
data you won't see it the the other
issue son was running with data driven
is that if you've got a bunch of
campaigns it's not very good at looking
at users cross campaign so that's told
the other downside you sometimes get
into it if you don't have a lot of
conversions you have a whole lot not a
problem at all so the other thing we
want to look at attribution for
is how do different devices compare so
if we just look at attribution modeling
and we say how does that words do or how
does Facebook do how does Twitter do
right that's going to show us how users
do across all devices what we often see
especially in business to businesses
would be to be marketing is that
Mobile's horrible all right okay so
there's exceptions right will
occasionally see b2b companies that
mobile is amazing
most companies Moe is horrible and so if
you just go with your analytics and you
say Wow
no one clicks on mobile ads and converts
we should just we should bid mobile way
way down so what we want to do right is
say let's look at our channels and let's
segment our channels by devices now once
we can see the device options let's look
at our attribution modeling and let's do
things like compare position base to
last click to even linear right within
our segmentation of channel groupings
and and devices so if we see that hey
paid search on a desktop
most of our conversions are our last
click and paid search on a mobile device
most our conversions are first click
right what that tells you is that via
paid search they're finding you on
mobile they're converting on desktop so
mobile may be undervalued no other times
you may look at that and say yep what
was horrible for us right but when you
when you think about the value of
different device types right it's not
about last click right it's about
customer journeys customers have very
wandering journeys so it's more about
saying how are they interacting with us
on this device and so we could use that
data to set our bid modifiers right last
year Google started actually using
device but modifiers
on cpa bidding they don't use the other
modifiers for cpa bidding but they do
use device modifiers and cpa betting and
robot spinning and so by looking at the
value of devices it gives you a better
picture of how how our mobile device is
doing because for some people mobile is
where it's all at others it looks
terrible but until you do a channel
device comparison by models that's
really one scan you're going to see okay
this is how people are really doing this
journey with us
right across channels and devices so we
can actually model that appropriately
now the thing is with a tribution we're
assuming that users are coming back to
our site more than once so if users are
coming once and they convert we can live
up for last click world it doesn't
matter right but for most companies
that's not a true statement so if
attribution matters you're basically
saying users are coming to our site more
than once before they buy so that also
means audiences matter if you're doing
attribution bidding you have enough data
and care enough with the customer
experience you should have a very good
audience strategy in place right so with
AdWords you can do audiences based on
your website usage which is often you
know remarketing or LSA you can do it
based on customer match which is based
on your CRM data but you know Nielsen
did a study this is this is about 18
months old now I'm although this number
is only going to continue to grow is
that consumers visit websites at least
six times on average in the purchase
process so the average checkout takes
six visits and I say checkout this could
be a forum Phil could be a phone call
it's all conversions six times on
average so this is why attribution so
importance great years ago all the touch
points were mostly offline and we had a
couple
once online real simple did you last
click it actually worked in many cases
on but as more and more touch points or
online someone's watching TV they do a
search on their phone they think about
it the next day they're on their
computer or they do it other search and
look on it you know later other other
it's in the evening and their to do a
search on their phone they come back the
next day and they're on their computer
and actually by rate as for touch points
that's not an uncommon experience three
of those just contributed to the
converse didn't actually convert the
user right the last one did and so if
you need attribution you need audiences
so you know when you think about
attribution this lets you put fractional
values on your conversions right so so
did interior value these conversions
properly across the funnel then you
should also should be ad testing across
the funnel to understand how ads early
in the funnel get users engaged and how
ads later in the funnel close someone
when you're using attribution now you've
got fraction data so now you can easily
set rules for engrams search terms
negative keywords if a query should be
positive or negative right so a lot of
times like we look at our search query
data we say hey we got twenty clicks and
no conversions we're using less click
well let's maybe look at bounce rate or
something but if we've got fractional
data now I can even see how those
low-volume queries are actually
contributing especially we wanted to
engrams
now the thing is you must track
everything for attribution to work
correctly so this was a site and they
were only initial attracting in their
website visits well okay there they've
got 1200 conversions but they actually
have 4,000 so they're missing a large
percentage so the added phone call
tracking it jumped up quite a bit bad
other chat tracking something a little
more better in store tracking now they
can see the full picture of a user so
with attribution modeling you only get
to model based on obviously the data you
have if you have two untracked
conversions they're not going to be in
your model right so you need to look at
your site and say eh how are all the
ways someone can convert with us right
can they call us can they chat we have a
chat bot can they send a text message
I'm is it just a form phone the website
can they walk into our store right how
can they convert then make sure you're
tracking all the different methods that
they can convert we see all the time
people who don't track phone calls make
very poor decisions with attribution
because often phone calls have a higher
conversion rate then a website visit
does and so attribution done properly
means you have access to all your
conversion data so if you have leaks you
places you're not tracking conversions
right that is a place that's not being
used in your attribution so when we
examine the models right last click this
is often low competition areas or you're
a true market leader and you're just not
worried about awareness ever knows who
you are and it's conservative growth
right it seems they know they know about
us already so it's a very conservative
growth model right time decay a little
more aggressive linear says value at all
the same position based starts moving
towards that growth oriented right maybe
you're new to markets where you have a
high competition arena and so you care a
lot about how do they first find us
right awareness starts the user down the
funnel path in closing and then finally
if you're really just focused on pure
growth I'm you're brand new to the
market there is no search following yet
there's not a lot of brand awareness yet
you might work with first click so we'll
often see companies who are they're a
startup that get funded they're a first
click company they start getting data
maybe
I'm a position based company unless
they're a true
maybe b2c app or something they really
get into time decay and last clique they
either state position based or move to
data-driven right and so it's a very
common entrance if you're purely direct
response and then you only care about
direct response then you may solve lies
click look your analytics and say wow we
want to be direct response average
visitor is three times
let's look splits use time decay it's
actually in a better show how you
inactive users so the models it's not
though there's a best or worst model
right they're different so one step is
how do we evaluate our channels where
you step one channel valuation step two
a devaluation right is the ad welcoming
users to our site or closing users are
moving along the journey right step
three bid based on the fractional
conversions that the touch points bring
in and so those all three of those ways
you should be using attribution for so
you know some things set to remember
right use attribution models to examine
channels for efficiency right and
contribution now if click the conversion
is greater than one point five you
probably want to ask you Shamal for
bidding it clicks a good version really
is 1.1 1.2 save yourself time you
probably don't need to get an
attribution right but you have to track
everything anything not tracked is not
going to take it into account with
attribution right so DDA data-driven
attribution right it's useful if if you
have a lot of conversions it's not
useful if you don't because you just get
stuck linear and if you're doing an
attribution model you put it into
Adwords you turn on CPA or LS bidding
you're automating attribution management
right so but when you use attribution
analysis is easier because you're taking
account these these fractional
conversions now this is today right what
we will see
and software evolution over the next 24
to 36 months is touchpoints across
channels for attribution right now you
can say okay
our users go to AdWords search adverse
display Facebook and they can work off
Twitter all right but you can't see the
individual Facebook post they clicked on
compared to AdWords search query
all right the data gets very thin very
quickly but we will start to see a rise
of what it looks like to take fractional
conversions by touchpoint cross channels
into one journey with us that's the
future that's what we're moving towards
in the next few years so keep learning
we love this stuff I hope that comes
across how much we just enjoy paid
search on things you can do my next
webinar is going to be on the
demographics of ad creation and
persuasion
how would you serve a different ad with
a different imagery to a male versus a
female alright how to use PPC tools so
on approximately nuts and we'll go
through how to use PPC tools and really
the art of being productive and then
finally in June we'll go through how
brands test ads so getting some some
large-scale ad testing and how brands
especial knows have a lot of legal
considerations um test their ads make
sure they get great results and with
that I'm going to hand it back to to Dan
for a moment to see if we were any good
questions yeah well thank you very much
Brad that was really in table and you
you think that this is something that
was this is a little in the weeds for a
lot of a lot of direct marketers but the
information you can get from this ad
management is really really useful
particularly in explaining the the big
difference between between conversions
and like just record analytics so we
have a few questions coming in on this
and here's one from Tanya and Tanya is
asking are there any specific examples
of types of companies or industries that
these two models make sense for a
position based versus time decay
obviously you guys are leading towards
position based yes so like we we worked
with someone got a large weight loss
companies so Nutrisystem or um I wait
watch yourself or three all of them want
to be last click but none of them are
and so time decay makes sense because
it's a subscription-based business where
most people know about them so it's not
so much about awareness it's how do we
get you in our system right we're we're
like us at Alice's we're a SAS program
um we're still moving off like five
years but but you know we've got decent
market shares not huge so we care about
how people found us and why they finally
convert which is position based so it's
it's usually in in areas where awareness
is still a question not everyone knows
your name then usually position base
makes more sense when you're a household
name then often you may go more to time
decay because everyone knows who you are
even though they may not know your whole
offering so I can still argue position
based long times over time decay but
that's usually what you end up with a
CMO standpoint okay well that's a that
makes a lot clearer
so the here's another question and this
is coming from Tom so client Tom had
declined a large manufacturing company
and he's working he says he's working
with recently and it doesn't use any
attribution modeling at all they're all
usually briefed by the media agency on
impressions and clicks and as a digital
analyst shall I recommend starting by
using last click model the client is not
using Google Analytics fully yet so what
what can Tom do to kind of get them on
that word a great question great
question right so number one I use
Google Analytics because everyone has
access to it you can do this and Adobe
core metrics right all the all the big
analytics system have this type of
modeling
it um you have to start somewhere
last clique is a great place to start
right you can't start by putting in some
complicated model with no conversion
tracking so step one is to tell them we
want to know impressions clicks
conversions right and conversions if
you're manufacturing probably are you
know either on-site contacts um in a lot
of phone calls and then you may even
have tertiary ones like catalog
downloads or things like that they get
sent up to the individual salespeople
for the different manufacturing
companies gotta start somewhere at last
click is a great place to start it gets
you data starts things flowing lets you
know what's going on so you can pick
something that fits the business better
but step one track the conversions and
just make them I mean they should be
doing this right giving you actual
conversion information great well that's
good that's a that's excellent advice
so that's all the questions we have at
this time so I just want to say thanks
again to brad geddes for joining us
today
a reminder to our audience that you can
rewatch and share this webinar instantly
right now if you go to youtube and just
search for go to the simply learned
channel you can you can find it up there
pretty easily easily and for those of
you who registered through WebEx please
keep an eye out for follow-up emails in
about a week or so with our written
wrap-up of this webinar and also the
video and more also remember to follow
brad geddes on twitter at BG theory
that's at BG theory for more information
on pay-per-click best practices and more
so if you have any further questions
that didn't get addressed during today's
presentation just feel free to tweet us
at simply learn or comment on YouTube
and we'll get back to you and of course
for a full schedule of all upcoming
webinars and events please head over to
our Facebook page and join us for as
Brad mentioned his previews for his
upcoming webinars coming up in the next
months or so so Brad thanks again for
joining us oh thank you damn for doing a
great job hosting us and moderating
right well my pleasure and see you all
next time hi there if you like this
video subscribe to the simply learn
youtube channel and click here to watch
similar videos to nerd up and get
certified click here